Öncelikle Herkese merhaba güzel bir
İzmir gününde sizlerle beraberim içim
açılı açıkçası hem buranın atmosferinden
hem de Buradaki arkadaşların bizi
karşılamasından İstanbul'u biliyorsunuz
biraz ajandalar yoğun Karamsarlık var
Ben bugün içinizi biraz daha karartmaya
geldim Aslında temsil ettiğim temsil
ettiğim Aslında şirketler çok teknoloji
odaklı Biz ve teknolojiyi her zaman bizi
ileriye götüren hayatlarımızı
değiştirecek ve Devrim yaratacak bir şey
olarak anlatıyoruz ama ben burada
farkındalık seviyemizin yükselmesi
gerektiğini düşünüyorum
kendimden kısaca bahsedeyim ben neler
yaptım aslında kendi hayatımı da weblere
bölecek olursam ben ve birimde
mühendisim endüstri mühendisiydim yani
akademiyi çok sevdim biraz daha devam
etsem kalacaktım zaten ve Türk ve kule
baş şirketlerle çalıştım sonrasında
şirketim için bölüm değiştirdim
pazarlama uzmanı oldum markaları
yönettim ve 31 yaşların başına da farklı
bir farklılık seviyesine geldim Belki de
dedim ki kendim için bir şey yapmak
istiyorum o yüzden de biraz daha böyle
bir girişim tarafında diğer konuşmacada
bahsettiği alanlarda faaliyet gösterdim
bugün geldiğimizde ben kendi tanımlarken
biraz zorlanıyorum çünkü çok farklı
sektörlerin içindeyim işte bir yaratıcı
sektör tarafından reklam ajansını temsil
ediyorum diğer tarafta bir yaratıcı
teknoloji şansımız var markalar ülkeler
seviyesinde projeler geliştiriyoruz
Diğer tarafta da farklı işte bir yaşayan
enerji şirketim var o yüzden de ben
bunların hepsini kesişim noktasında çok
böyle hayatımızdan çıkardığımız ve
biraz üzerine düşünmemiz gereken bir
kelimenin olduğunu düşünüyorum muhakeme
ben kendimi Her zaman sıfırlarken yani 0
noktasında
kendine ilgili düşüncelere daldığımda ve
ben ne yapıyorum Can hayatın neresinde
ve nereye gitmek istiyor derken bu
kelime aklıma geliyor USA var mı hüküm
verme ve bir Sorun çözmek için çıkar yol
arama şimdi bunu tam karşılığında da
aslında dediğim gibi temsil ettiğim
sektörlerde şöyle bir kelime var gelecek
sürekli geleceği konuşurken Aslında biz
geçmişin mahkemesine yaparak
konuştuğumuzu düşünüyoruz ama ben burada
biraz böyle şüpheciyim Çünkü gelecek
nasıl tanımlanıyor daha gelmemiş olan
zaman İlerideki bilinmeyen zaman ileride
yaşanacaklar şimdi bu kadar bilinmesi ne
olduğu bir bilinmezi barındıran bir
kelimeyi
muhakeme ile birleştirdiğimizde aslında
Biz şöyle bir gelecek formasyonuna
geliyoruz ne diyoruz öte dünyalar
teknoloji bir yol hikayesi ve bugün
oturup 2020'lerin başından 2080'lere
kadar bunun tahminlerini yapmaya
başlıyoruz
Diyoruz ki iş hayatı yapay yaşam dijital
yaşam fiziksel yaşam
farklı dikeylerde farklı gelişmeler işte
bugün uzaktan çalışma hayatımızın bir
gerçeği iken 2080'lere geldiğimizde
yapay şirketlerden bahsedeceğiz diyoruz
sesli asistanlar yapay zekayı konuşurken
gelecekte tamamen yapay yaşama
geçeceğimiz ve insansı yapay zekayı
hayatımızı bir parçası yapacağımızı
konuşuyoruz ya da dijital yaşamda işte
5G teknolojilerini konuşurken gelecekte
dijital gerçeklikle Yapılan bu
lansmanların devamında bambaşka
temsillerimiz olacağını konuşuyoruz
fiziksel yaşam en az konuştuğumuz Ama
orada da bizi birer Makine gibi
konumlandırıyor teknoloji aslında ve
diyor ki izleme teknolojileri gelecekte
hizmet olarak senin için fiziksel
Hayattaki her şeye dönüşecek
şimdi
tabi burayı konuşmak biraz da kolay
Çünkü sürekli Devrim oluyor aslında biz
geçtiğimiz hafta yepyeni bir
farkındaysanız gözlük lansmanı izledik
artık orada dendi ki önceki gözlükler
sanal viya Gözlüklerim
karşı tarafta göz teması kurulmadı ve
işlemcisi yüksek olan makinalarla gözün
işlem kapasitesi ile uyuşmadığı için o
göz temasını korumak üzerine yapılmalı
dendi
Peki biz insan metabolizmasını
fiziki özelliklerini işte Düşünsel
yolculuğunu işin içine katıp bu
lansmanları yaparken bir gözlük markası
çıkartırken burada geçmişin var etmesini
doğru yapıyor muyuz Aslında o cam fanus
meselesine de geliyor muhakeme tarafında
Biz o cam fanusu tanımlıyor muyuz burada
geçmişin mahkemesini yapıyorum yüzerken
de şöyle bakmak lazım konuya
Şimdi biz hep bir yere gittiğimizi
sanıyoruz bence Ben de bu devamlı
sürekli bunun üzerine konuşuyorum bunun
üzerine projeler geliştiriyorum ama
dönüp baktığımda böyle biraz hani
felsefeye dokunduğumda Ne bileyim tarih
okuduğumda farklı içeriklerle
beslendiğimde görüyorum ki aslında biz
her zaman ileri gitmiyoruz biz çok
gittiğimizi sanıyoruz ama geçmişi
tekrarlıyoruz bir şeyleri tekrar tekrar
buluyoruz ve o kısımda Bence bir şeyler
kaçıyor protez demiş ki aslında insan
her şeyin ölçüsüdür
döndüğümüz yerde İşte o mahkemenin
us'a ulaşmak tarafında ölçüyü kaçırmamak
için insan olduğumuzu hatırlamamız lazım
2080 yolculuğunda fark ettiyseniz insana
daha çok bir şey yoktu Biz sürekli
insanı Aslında makinalarla ilk önce
beraber yaşamaya alıştırmak Sonrasında
da insanı makinalaştırmak üzerine
konuştuk O yüzden de insan olduğumuz
unutmamalıyız ve ölçüyü Aslında oradaki
muhakeme odağında yapmalıyız
şimdi
18 ve 19 yüzyıllarda postümanizm
biliyorsunuz dünyada
bir karar mekanizması haline geldi biz
ne yaptık insanı öldürdük yani bilinen
insanı ve merkezi aslında bir önceki
konuşmada da buna değinildi İşte o
Merkezi yapılar daha dağınık yapılar
haline gelmeye Ta o zaman başladı
kostümanizm nedir peki bugün
konuştuğumuz makineler yapay zeka ve
hatta ölümsüzlük Amacımız ne Aslında
bildiğimiz insanı tekrar öldürmek ikinci
bir Aslında web Hani web bir web2
diyoruz ya
İnsan bir insan iki ve insan üç diye ben
bunun adlandırayım şimdi sizin için biz
aslında insan iki şeyi tasarlıyoruz
İnsan 3 zaten şu an için O gördüğünüz
2080'den sonra 2100'lere geldiğimizde
bambaşka bir makine olacak peki burada
insana karşı Üstün insan yarışına
girerken bize soruldu mu Ya da bizim
fikrimizi alındı mı İşte burada yine
mahkemeye dönüyoruz bu hikayenin Biz
neresindeyiz bireyler olarak Neye evet
diyoruz kullandığımız araçlar
hayatımıza kattığımız teknolojiler
sizlerin kullandığı arayüzler İşte o
sosyal medya mecraları Bunların hepsi
Evet hayatınızı bir değişmez parçası
diyoruz
bir okulda mesela tüm oradaki işleyişin
devam edebilmesi için şu an teknolojiye
ihtiyacımız var teknolojiyi çekersek bir
çok şey dağılır ama aslında manuel de
birçok şeyi yapabiliriz O yüzden de bu
insan ve üstün insan kavramlarını
Konuşurken de 21
ütopyasına geliyoruz insanlığın blok
zincirini programlamak blok zincir neydi
Aslında dağınık ağalar üzerinden bilgiyi
sürekli kılmaktı ve buradaki paylaşımı
hiyerarşisinde de eşitliği ön plana
çıkarmaktı
şimdi blok zincir Tabii çok farklı
alanlarda
Öncelikle 1990'larda bankacılık
sektöründe konuşuluyor sonrasında farklı
sektörlerde tekrar
Yani söz konusu oluyor fakat
gerçekleştirilemiyor işte o da zaten o
Meta virüsün biraz da
Ütopya olarak kalmasına sebep oluyor
çünkü
altyapı çok güçlüyken Eğer ki içerikler
içerik hazır değilse ya da içecekler çok
dağınıksa kurumlar kendi arasında belli
protokollerle bunları paylaşamıyorlarsa
İşte o blockchain dediğimiz sistemler
hayata Geçirmiyor şimdi peki insanın
blok şey nedir
insanoğlu
Biz tarihsel süreçte
Anılar biriktirdik
bizi hayvandan ayıran özellikleri ve
hayvan
olduğumuz özellikleri Aslında
harmanladık ve düşünen varlıklar olarak
bugün Geldiğimiz noktada
makinalara 1960 senesinde Aslında bu
konuyla ilgili çok güzel araştırmalar
var makinelere
güvenlik ve geleceğimizi onların üzerine
kurduk şimdi peki burada kaybettiğimiz
şey neydi bu süreç içindeki bilgiydi
bilgiyi sürekli kılamıyoruz bilgi bizle
bizim geldiğimiz gibi hayat akışında
bizi takip etmiyor erişimimiz çok
kısıtlı hala kütüphanelere ihtiyacımız
var hala orada da markalar markalar bize
serbest sağlayıcı olarak hizmet veriyor
O yüzden de aslında bu blog zinciri
programlarsak insanlık hep beraber
hareket etmeyi ve İşte o muhakeme
yeteneğini birlikte Yönetmeyi öğrenecek
peki burada muhakemeden vazgeçersek
insanlıktan vazgeçeceğiz gibi bir
yaklaşımla mı acaba burada
sonuçlandırmalıyız
Ee bence Evet Ee her şeyi sorgulamalıyız
Çünkü kararlar bizim adımıza veriliyor
ve bizim olmadığımız coğraflarda
veriliyor ve Hani ben coğrafyanın kaderi
olduğuna inanıyorum Ee Ama bunun bir
şekilde de önde durmaya çalışıyorum
çünkü konuştuğum şeyler yaratmaya
çalıştığım şeyler ekibimle beraber ki bu
alanda Z kuşağı Bizim için en önemli
kaynaklıyım Ben sizden çok şey
öğreniyorum
ekibimizde birçok Z kuşağından
arkadaşımız var hatta artık kuşaklar da
kalmadı çünkü biz birçok sistemi sizler
için kurduk kurucu neslis Sizler onu
kullanan annesi dersiniz ve bizim
Aslında sizden öğreneceğimiz çok şeyler
var ve Burada hep beraber biz burada
insanlığımızdan vaz mı geçeceğiz yoksa
makineler değil Bizler mi kazanacağız
ona karar vermemiz gerekiyor o yüzden de
son 4 ayda lansmanı yapılmış ve dünyada
en çok indirilen ve en çok kullanılan
Yapay Zeka üzerinden bahsediyoruz
farkındaysanız
1960 lira demiştim size 1960'larda
makineler ve yapay zeka için moron
deniyordu kelime olarak bunu silikon
vadesinde birçok konuşmada
dinleyebilirsiniz Peki moronlar morond
diye tabir ettiğimiz makineleri
geliştirip Şimdi de hayranlık duymaya
bizi ne etti İşte bunun muhakemesi de
önemli biz neden kendi yarattığımız
şeyleri hayran oluyoruz ve neden sürekli
insanımızdan vazgeçmeye çalışıyoruz
Bence burada çok önemli bir yol
ayrımındayız ve
etrafımızdaki her şeyinde insan icadı
olduğunu unutmadan hayatlarımızı
sürdürmemiz gerekiyor o sistemde Yaratan
da biziz onların içinde yürüyen aksiyon
alanında biziz O yüzden
ben konuşmamı biraz böyle teknoloji
bağlamında bana sorulan sorulara her
zaman teknoloji anlatarak teknoloji
projesi getirerek ya da onun
stratejisini anlatarak devam ettirmek
durumundayım profesyonel hayatımda ama
Can olarak insanca olarak bizim burada
yapmamız gereken insan icadının olduğunu
unutmayıp teknolojinin
ona aşık olup onun bizi geçip
insanlığımızdan ödün vermeyi itmesine
izin vermek olduğunu düşünüyorum çok
teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]